whether you have students taking a
summer class or not the school district
is offering free meals all summer long
jeremy j ford stopped at rex bell
elementary one of many schools around
the valley offering the service this is
one way of ccsd is letting the community
know that we care about them throughout
the school year in addition to the
summer ccsd communications specialist
maricio marin tells me it's the first
day to serve meals to children ages 2 to
18. many of our locations are just
getting ready for them they're ready but
this year there's one significant change
with no covert restrictions there will
be no drive through takeout service
they need to eat their food their
breakfast and their lunch here and that
is with or without the supervision of an
adult if parents are working or unable
to come our children can come here
receive a free meal from now throughout
the summer the usda summer meal program
happening at ccsd schools will happen
until we start school first day of
school for the new school year will be
august 8th jeremy j ford live local now